security cameras record the impact
of a sudden explosion in a residential
neighborhood just outside bangkok
the ground shook just like an earthquake
said residents
shattering windows all around the source
a huge chemical factory in somewhat
prakhan on the outskirts of the thai
capital
highly flammable materials used to make
foam packaging
quickly engulfed the complex in flames
that firefighters struggle to contain
we are trying to look for the injured
however the flames are quite high
so it takes quite an effort to look for
people rescuers are also spreading out
because we receive calls
for people who have injuries from
explosions from the extended area
one or two streets away from here there
are reports of falling debris
injuries from debris impacts on faces
and heads
the damage caused by the explosion was
considerable it's estimated the factory
alone has suffered more than 20 million
us dollars worth
70 homes are also seriously affected and
thousands of people have been evacuated
from within a wide radius of the factory
firefighters struggled throughout the
day to bring the blaze under control but
the flammable nature of the chemicals
made it a complicated and dangerous task
at times the flames taking over areas
the firefighters thought they had
under control as the day went on a huge
plume of smoke rose across the area
described by some witnesses as toxic and
visible across bangkok and beyond
when that finally clears there'll be
questions to answer
about the failure to control such
dangerous chemicals
tony chang al jazeera bangkok